The Woman Who is the Mother of Us
All
all humans can be traced back to a single
female known as Mitochondrial Eve.
This woman is thought to be the “mother”
of all humans alive today.
Seems like a big claim for scientists to make.
So how do they know this?
The simple explanation is that when an egg
is fertilized by a sperm, the DNA from the
father and mother join together in a process
known as recombination.
Certain DNA is only passed down from the mother
or father.
All mitochondrial DNA (mtDNA) come exclusively
from the mother, as an exact copy.
Over time however, there will occur predictable
mutations to mtDNA.
Biologists can compare samples from individuals
to determine how closely they are related-
the fewer these predictable mutations, the
closer the relationship.
The predictability of these mutations also
allows biologists to estimate the time at
which a certain mutation (i.e. ancestor) lived.
Beginning in 1987, several studies have been
conducted that show all humans alive today
have the same female ancestor and she lived
approximately 200,000 years ago.
A more detailed explanation is as follows.
Mitochondria are a type of organelle found
in almost all complex cells.
They are known as the power plants of the
cell because they supply an enzyme (more accurately
a co-enzyme) known as adenosine triphosphate
(ATP).
This ATP is the source for the chemical energy
needed by a cell to perform a wide range of
functions.
The DNA found within mitochondria have two
benefits.
They have 37 genes that rarely mutate, so
they can be easily used as the model for an
evolutionary clock, and these same genes have
subsections that mutate in a predictable manner
so biologists can use it as a reference for
age.
Sperm have only a few mitochondria (and thus
mitochondrial DNA) in their tails.
They use them to power their quest to the
egg.
As the sperm enters the egg, only the chromosomes
found in the head of the sperm are preserved
and used in the recombination process to create
new cells.
This is because the rest of the sperm cell
is broken down by enzymes within the egg.
So the mitochondrial DNA in the tail is lost
and the only type to survive is supplied by
the mother.
As the human population grows from one generation
to the next, women transfer this DNA evidence
to their daughters.
They, in turn, transfer it to their daughters.
Should a woman have only a son, their mtDNA
is lost, because it will never be passed to
his children.
However, there have been a few rare cases
in which mitochondrial DNA was found recombined
from both parents.
Some skeptics of the Mitochondrial Eve theory
use this to cast doubt on the hypothesis.
This opposition is somewhat dubious as those
few cases occur in people who are typically
far too biologically deficient to have offspring.
Thus, the prevailing assumption is that these
unfortunate people have something seriously
wrong with their DNA and the abnormal recombination
of mtDNA will never get into the human population
because of it.
Even though biologists have shown that all
people are descended from one person, this
does not mean that only one female was alive
at that time.
It simply means only one set of genes have
been passed down from a single point in history.
Most researchers agree that “Eve” was
not the only women alive because the fossil
record shows much older specimens.
From “Java man” at about 800,000 years
to “Lucy”, the earliest known remains
which are approximately 1-4 million years
old.
There are several theories about how just
one set of genes could have survived.
The most likely is a bottleneck of the human
population that would set the stage for an
evolutionary “lucky mother”.
There have been several possible bottlenecks
in history.
One report, written in 1998, showed approximately
70,000 years ago humanity was down to around
15,000 people.
It showed the reason behind the bottleneck
was an ice age that lasted about a 1,000 years.
Other reasons bottlenecks could have happened
are: an asteroid impact or volcanic eruption
causing drastic climate change; a continuous,
widespread plague; or any situation that caused
male offspring to have a better chance of
survival, leaving relatively few women around
to pass on their genes.
While no definitive proof exists that these
occurred, most researchers believe a combination
of one or all of these factors are behind
why we all have a common ancestor.
There is another type of genetic test that
can trace all humans alive today back through
their father’s ancestors.
This uses what is known as the Y chromosome
and shows that all people today can trace
their lineage back to a single father known
as “Y Chromosome Adam”.
Before you start throwing fuel on any religious
fire, Y Adam lived at a completely different
time then Eve.
Approximately 60,000 -90,000 years ago.
How can this be?
Mitochondrial Eve is simply the most recent
common ancestor of mtDNA.
Y chromosomal Adam is the most recent common
ancestor for Y DNA.
They did not have to be a couple for both
of their genes to be the source for all current
humans.